you're as fit as i've ever seen you bro
when we first started hanging out you
were uh you were you were a little
chubbier yeah you didn't have abs 2 30.
exactly now you're what
um like 215 right now gotcha so and
you're in great shape i'm still
overweight so
okay but the point is you're you're
you're
you're in shape you're in great you're
in great shape you're training i've seen
you boxing a lot lately i think at one
point you were calling out like belfort
yeah to fight him yeah so my question is
and we'll get to the legacy thing
are you training
to fight and if so are you going to be
the first person to knock out jake paul
because i could see that happening
mike what's it do you do you're a jake
paul fan yes i am really you you would
not knock him out
if you're going to fight for sure you
know but like
person-to-person yeah i love jake and
logan really great friends of mine
they've shown support way before
instagram days cool you know and me on
the way up so i would never come you
know bad-mouth a guy just for publicity
right because that's just against the
man code you know 100 but yeah for sure
i love fighting i love boxing yeah
martial arts wrestling jiu jitsu
all that stuff man this is separate from
animal stuff this is this is just a
competitive well that's the inner yeah
what is that yeah no that's just the i
want to [ __ ] go you know like you
want to play football you like my
territory you sniffing my girl what you
want to you want to wrestle
what's that switch that you have to hit
in order to be a what is that
animalistic tendency what is that it's
just
just com competition
don't you once you like i'm
a whole different person
mentally you know i'm just
i'll die in the treadmill just to beat
you
like will smith at one point says
exactly
smith right yeah exactly literally die
in a treadmill you just won't beat me
wow you know and we talked about team
sports earlier i played a lot of team
sports growing up but i got my first
taste of individual sport where you're
you're held accountable for what you do
before your match
you know you can be on a team and
[ __ ] which i was i was great at
doing that's why i love team sports
group projects in school we got five
people all right i ain't doing [ __ ]
i'll show it when it's ready and you
guys just tell me what i'm gonna do the
last day but when they when they came to
an individual sport
wrestling it's like yo if you don't run
you don't do your techniques right you
don't take your time and breathe you
don't do your cardio it's on you you're
gonna they're gonna whip your ass in
front of everybody and it's one on one
who you're gonna point the finger at
ain't the quarterback's fault ain't the
point in guard's fault ain't the
goalie's fault it's your fault
so
after i got my first taste of that i'm
like yo
so where do you see yourself fighting
and you see yourself actually legacy
it's like i want to be a warrior you
know like i'm a uh warrior for animals
you know if i can make money which i
know i can in boxing or mma or anything
and i can put it towards animals that's
what i'm gonna do if my dog wants me to
buy all the food on all three we're
fighting
you know and i'm in a window right now
all jokes aside i'm 28 i'll be
32 in five years
i got a prime window
once a male hits 32 he's at his peak
physically and mentally you know so i
know i'm aware now it's like yo hey
[ __ ] you're 28. if you dedicate
the next five years of your life like
you did the last five years of your life
to just straight animals look what you
got if you didn't if you dedicate a
little bit of your time
your physical time working out you've
seen i went from 2 30 down to
[ __ ] ripped yeah if i can do that and
be dedicated in an art of martial arts
and i already know i have the
the fire inside to compete because i
love it and when you throw that and say
why are you competing it's not for the
money for me it's for the money for my
animals you know i want to save my
animals not my animals in my house like
if i can make 40 million dollars
fighting and i can say yo i'm gonna give
this gorilla an elephant foundation 30
mil
exactly that's some badass [ __ ] well you
know
disney's business model um i believe it
was pixar or disney they said
you know we don't make movies to make
money we make money to make movies and
that's essentially you brother you don't
mess with animals to make money you make
money so you can feed your animals so
exactly they're my kids you know when
you're a parent i'm pretty i'm not a i'm
not a human parent but i'm an animal
parent you know and
and you got a lot of kids to take care
of i got kids to take care of that i
love dearly that i give my life for you
know so
there's no no in my book for my kids i'm
gonna do whatever i gotta do read
whatever i gotta read travel wherever i
gotta travel to go to wherever i gotta
go through
work any type of business i gotta work
to make sure my kids have what they need
you